hey guys it is 21st of July today my
name is Jess and here's the biggest
gaming news of the minute a huge new
patch for star wars battlefront has
arrived which has added the offline
skirmish mode and made a bunch of other
changes skirmish lets you play the
Walker assault or Fighter Squadron modes
against bots either by yourself or with
a friend online the console version also
features split-screen the patch also
tweaks the partner spawn system so you
can't partner spawn when you're right by
an enemy other changes include an
increase in time between rounds various
weapon balance alterations and you
balance changes for the game's heroes
and villains the mighty update is 12
gigabytes on xbox one and is likely to
be of similar size on ps4 and PC for all
the nitty-gritty details on this one
head to our story on games blood next up
there's been a whole lot of buzz over
cross-platform play and rocket League is
raring to get developer psionics told
IGN they're super ready to implement ps4
and xbox one cross-platform play say
they're at the point where all we need
is to go ahead on the Sony side studio
vice president Jeremy Dunham added we
can in less than a business day turn it
on and have it up and working their
problem it had literally take a few
hours to propagate throughout the whole
world so really we're just waiting on
the permission to do so Microsoft has
previously said they are ready to
connect to other platforms I'll sony has
been a bit more vague on that front
dunham however doesn't sound deterred
saying we're still very confident that
Sony are eventually going to open those
doors and work on the sin but we're also
really understanding that it's going to
take a while especially given all the
ramifications of everything it was just
as much of a surprise to them as I think
the rest of the world when microsoft
said they would do it the witcher 3
developer center project red is also
jumping on the cross-platform play
bandwagon and campaigning to get
standalone card game gwent playable
across platforms CEO marcin Levinsky
told IGN we are keeping our fingers
crossed for rocket league paving the way
microsoft already confirmed whence
cross-play feature not only between xbox
one and pc and also other consoles if
they allow it we also do have a
technical solution in place for ps4 and
would love to add sony's platform to
cross play at the start of open beta all
we need is a green light from sony so
far sony has only publicly said they are
open-minded to partnerships but not
address the matter any further let me
know if you'd like to see them give
cross played to go ahead be sure to head
to game [ __ ] the stories on Pokemon go
and the area mini and come by same time
tomorrow for the top stories of the
whole week I will see you then